[Music]
adam is in houston texas adam welcome to
the ramsay show
thank you sir it's been a pleasure
talking to you today you too what's up
hey um
my name is adam i'm 34. i came to this
blitzen country in 2009.
um
basically my my network is 1.2 million
and i own
five rental properties and one
home which i live in
and currently i have one eighty three
thousand dollars in cash
and i have six hundred thirty two
thousand 000 in total debt with all the
rentals including my primary house so
i'm just trying right now me and my wife
to
uh slow down and trying to pay down the
debt and we are in a debate right now so
instead of paying down the rentals or
paying down
our house first
so why is this in the middle of now
do you owe money on your personal
residence
yes how much
198 and you have 183 in the bank
yes what's your household income
uh
162.
okay so you got 400 on the rentals and
100 and 200 on your home give or take
that's and also including the eighteen
thousand dollars card that's including
six hundred thirty two thousand uh
because i have i use um those credits uh
what they call like monitoring and you
just count how much how many dollars
they owe and it shows the total debt i
have is 632 but it's including eighteen
thousand dollars with my car too do you
have car debt
eighteen thousand yeah you need to pay
the car off today and then i would work
on paying my personal residence off and
then i would work on paying the rentals
off
okay all right that sounds um
that's what i was talking to my wife was
telling me
we can keep the cash it's there and we
keep added to it every month if there is
an opportunity we can jump on it if it's
not we just like no there's not an
opportunity the opportunity right now is
get your debt cleaned up
okay and then when you've got zero debt
you're gonna have so much cash coming
out your ears then you're gonna see some
opportunities and you're going to pay
cash for them
from this point forward you have the
opportunity to stabilize this portfolio
that you've grown and if you continue to
go the other direction you're going to
continue to destabilize it and
eventually lose it
yeah
because you like buying real estate and
debt doesn't bother you and it needs to
start bothering you this is going to
catch up with you
yeah
you got here okay and so far you're okay
but it this
and
but you're like the guy who put one
quarter in the slot machine and won and
you think it's going this is going to
work every time and
i've done this a long time adam and i
own a bunch of real estate and i love
real estate
so if you want to you called the ramsey
show and you weren't going to expect to
hear anything except get out of debt and
you also said what's the fastest way i
can get out of my debt and now you're
going yeah but you're saying yeah in a
way that makes me think you're not doing
any of this stuff we're telling you yeah
people tend to get a little starry-eyed
with real estate investing and i just
got a message from a guy yesterday on
instagram who lost his shirt with this
he got a little excited about real
estate investing did it before he was
ready and he ended up losing a ton of
money and so i was trying to help him
clean up this mess and i don't think
adam's gonna go there today yeah i don't
think that's the issue but but what the
issue is with adam is uh when he says
stuff like well i've got this money set
aside for an opportunity translation i'm
getting ready to go buy more real estate
on debt
okay and um as soon as i see something i
like you know and right now is not a
good time to buy real estate anyway it's
a great time to sell it great time to
pay off your debt though amen and amen
always a good day for that amen